Okay, welcome back. Welcome to video
number 24, where Chris is going to show
you on the computer how you can actually
calculate your own beta as long as you can
get the data. Now, there's a couple of
things here. The only reason why you would
actually go and calculate your own beta is
really because you can't get the beta,
number anywhere else. There's a lot of
online resources where you can actually
get beta. So go onto all of the typical
financial websites and you'll see that
you'll get beta values for most stocks on
most websites. What you'll typically see
is the three year beta. The problem with
going on these websites sometimes is that
you don't actually know the length of time
that you're looking at in terms of beta.
The download section, the one that you're
looking at in all of the spreadsheets, the
beta that you're looking at there is the
five year rolling beta, which is from a
company in the United States called Value
Line. Now, if you have a beta of that
length of time, five years, it's very,
very unlikely that over short spaces of
time, the beta is going to change a great
deal.
So, if you're going to change the
spreadsheets and use these spreadsheets
and use these online resources, you don't
really have to change your beta too often.
If you're going to use the online
resources and download them. And if you're
using five year or three year beta, but if
you're using very short term beta,
obviously you're going to have to update
this a lot more often.
So, if you're using three month, six month
or one year beta, then you are going to
have to update them. But I wouldn't worry
about it too much. If you're using three
and five year, you can update these every
six to 12 months.
Now, the other thing with beta, when
you're calculating your beta, when you're
calculating your own beta, you can update
these every six to 12 months.
Now, the other thing with beta, when
you're calculating your own beta is that
it's actually a step further from really
what a retail trader should massively do.
be worrying about because what you really
should be worrying about is the positions
that you've got on.
Now the other thing with beta, when you're
calculating your own beta, is that it's
actually a step further from really what a
retail trader should massively be worrying
about.
Because what you really should be worrying
about is the positions that you've got on
and having the correct positions. That's
first and foremost.
This really comes secondary and one of the
reasons why we're showing you this is
because a lot of people will have the
objective of working in the industry one
day.
So either working for a hedge fund or
working at an investment bank.
This is another thing that you'd be
expected to know and understand and be
able to calculate if you were going into
the industry.
From a retail trader perspective, if you
can actually just get the beta, and
because beta isn't a perfect measure
anyway.
If you can get the beta and you're trying
to hedge out market risk as accurately as
possible, but we all know that it can't be
100% accurate.
Because relying on beta or relying on it
to be 100% accurate doesn't really work.
Beta is just a measure that we use in an
attempt to try and hedge out market risk
as best as we possibly can.
And beta can change. But if you use it
over long enough time periods, it should
be fairly accurate.
So don't worry about it too much if you're
watching Chris on the computer and you
think it's a bit too advanced for you.
If you can get the beta numbers, that's
fine. If your objective is to work in the
industry one day, then this is something
you'll have to learn.
So let's go over to the computer screen.
Chris is going to show you how to do it.
You've got the downloads with five year
rolling beta in the download section for
beta.
And you can actually go and get this
number on decent websites anywhere online.
So let's go over to the presentation.
Chris will show you how to do it.
And I'll see you at the end of the video
with a summary of everything that we've
learned so far.
Okay, so now Chris is going to show you
how you can calculate your own beta in
case you can't actually get beta publicly
from the websites that we usually look at.
Or you think the beta data is unreliable.
So we're going to use a very well known
stock in the United States and Chris is
going to show you how to do that now.
So let's calculate the beta. Take it away,
Chris.
In this video, I'm going to talk you
through how you can calculate your own
beta value using Excel.
So beta value is just a statistical
measure of the sensitivity of a stock to
the market.
And by market, what we typically mean as
industry practice to use the index in
which the stock that we're looking at is
listed in.
So in this example, we're going to use
Heinz as our stock, a consumer staple
stock that we'd expect to have low
sensitivity to the market.
And we will see how its returns correlate
with the S&P 500, which is the index in
which it's listed in.
And from that, we can obtain its
sensitivity, which is its beta value.
So let's go ahead and get started.
The first thing we need to do is gather
our data.
So if we go to Yahoo Finance and in the
ticker box, the enter symbol box in the
top left, we type HNZ for Heinz.
And select Heinz Company.
And then on the left hand side, navigate
to historical prices.
Now we're going to calculate a three year
beta, which is quite typical on websites
such as Bloomberg and other financial
websites.
They typically give you around a three to
five year rolling beta.
So we'll obtain our data from the 3rd of
March 2010 to the 3rd of March 2013.
And we'll get it on a weekly basis.
Update the table by clicking Get Prices.
Scroll to the bottom of the web page and
click Download to Spreadsheet.
And at this point you can save this file
on your hard drive or you can go ahead and
open the Excel spreadsheet straight away
as we're going to do and then save it once
you're in it.
Okay, so we'll just go to File, Save As,
Save it on Desktop, Save as HNZ Beta, Save
it as an Excel workbook.
That's fine.
So the first thing we'll do in this
spreadsheet is just adjust the Dates
column so we can see all the dates.
Okay, so to calculate beta we also need
the price data from the S&P 500 so we can
create returns columns for both HNZ and
the S&P 500 and see how they're
correlated.
So if we go back to Yahoo Finance and type
in S&P and select the S&P 500 from the
drop down list and again go to Historical
Prices.
And we need to make sure that we select
the data between the same range and with
the same frequency as we did before.
So that was March the 3rd, 2010 to March
the 3rd, 2013 on a weekly basis.
Make sure you update the table by clicking
Get Prices.
Scroll to the bottom of the web page and
click Download to Spreadsheet again.
And we'll just go ahead and open this
spreadsheet.
You don't need to save this file.
Okay, so now we've got our original sheet
which is the HNZ price values and this is
our S&P 500 prices.
So if we go back to the HNZ sheet and what
we're going to do is get rid of all these
columns of data that we don't need to
calculate returns and our beta value.
So what we'll do is just leave the close
column and the date column.
So if we select column B and hold CTRL and
select C, D, F and G.
So that will select the open high, low,
volume and adjusted close.
And then right click within the selection
and press delete.
And that will leave us just with the date
in column A and closing prices of HNZ in
column B.
And the next thing we want to do is import
the S&P 500 closing prices into this
spreadsheet, into column C.
So what we do is go back to the S&P 500
spreadsheet and we select column E and we
just press CTRL C once that's selected to
copy.
And then back in the HNZ spreadsheet go to
cell C1 and press CTRL V to paste.
Okay.
So to make this a little bit clearer what
we'll do is rename column B and C instead
of just close we'll rename them to their
appropriate asset names.
So in B1, cell B1 we'll rename that as HNZ
price and in, actually to make this
consistent, price brackets HNZ and in C1
price brackets S&P.
And adjust the columns as necessary, the
widths so we can fit all that in.
Okay.
So in column D what we'll do is create the
returns for HNZ over this period.
So let's head up that column in D1.
Actually we'll do it in column E.
In E1 we'll put returns brackets HNZ,
adjust the column.
And in F we'll do something similar but
with the S&P so we type in returns S&P
into that cell.
Now, we need to use the returns formula in
cell E2 and F2.
So in E2, it's the closing price of the
current day minus the closing price of the
previous day divided by the closing price
of the previous day.
And that gives us our return.
And we can copy that formula down easily
by navigating to the bottom of the
spreadsheet.
If we click on this data in column A, B
and C, we can press CTRL and down to go
down to the bottom of that data quickly.
We'll go across to column E and press CTRL
and up to select all the cells that we
want to copy down the formula in cell E2
down to.
So we've got all those cells selected.
We just press CTRL and that copies all of
the returns down.
And we'll do the same thing for the S&P.
So, equals the closing price today minus
the closing price yesterday divided by the
closing price yesterday gives us the
returns today.
And the same thing, we'll navigate to the
bottom of the spreadsheet.
CTRL and shift up to select all cells and
CTRL and D to copy all of that down.
So, if we just go down to the bottom of
the spreadsheet, what we'll see is there's
two cells there at the bottom that have
got errors.
This is because our returns formula
requires price data from a previous day.
And obviously in the bottom row, there is
no previous day.
So, that's giving us an error.
So, what we do is we just delete those two
cells by selecting them and pressing
delete on the keyboard.
Okay, so, now we've got our returns.
We'll just actually make this look a bit
better by selecting all our returns in the
Hines and S&P column.
So, I used CTRL, SHIFT starting from cell
E2.
I used CTRL, SHIFT, right arrow and down
arrow to select all that quickly.
With all that selected, right click inside
the selection.
Go to format cells.
And we're going to change the number
category to percentage.
Two decimal places is fine.
Okay.
So, in the next step, we're going to
calculate beta.
To do this, we need to use the data
analysis tool, which is located in the
data tab on the right hand side, over
here.
If you don't already have that there
installed on your Excel, you'll have to
install it manually using a plugin called
analysis tool pack.
And there's a guide on how you do that in
the accompanying PDF.
So, let's just go ahead and click data
analysis.
And we go to regression.
Select regression, press ok.
So, regression is just a statistical
procedure that we use to measure how well
certain variables in a model can explain
another variable that we're testing.
So, that also allows us to gain
sensitivity measures of each of these
variables.
And that's essentially what beta is.
So, to perhaps put that to make a bit more
sense in what we're actually doing here.
We're testing Heinz.
Heinz is our variable.
And we're testing it with a model of the
S&P.
So, we're testing how well the returns in
the S&P explain the returns in Heinz.
And by comparing those, by modelling that,
it will show us the coefficient, which is
the sensitivity of the S&P 500.
Sorry, it will give us a coefficient of
the S&P 500 that shows us the sensitivity
of Heinz to the S&P 500.
Ok, so let's just continue.
If you want to know a bit more about
regression, it is explained a little bit
more in the accompanying PDF.
And also, there's plenty of resources
online that you can look at as well.
But let's just go ahead and start.
So, our Y input range is our Heinz return.
So, in the Y input range box, we'll click
cell E2 and press CTRL-SHIFT and down.
And that will select all the Heinz
returns.
And then we click into the X input range
box and do the same for the S&P.
So, we click F2, cell F2, CTRL-SHIFT down
to select all of those cells.
And we want to display our regression in
this spreadsheet.
So, we change the output range from a new
worksheet to output range.
And be careful, because this throws our
selection back up to the Y input range,
which we've already selected.
And we don't want to edit that.
So, make sure you click off into the
output range box.
And we're going to display this in cell
I2.
And just before we press OK and display
our regression, we need to make sure that
we click the line fit plots box down here.
Which will show us a graphical
interpretation of our regression.
So, just select that and press OK.
OK, so just before we edit this data a
bit, let's just, or just before we look at
this data and I explain it a bit more,
let's just edit these columns so that they
show all this data properly.
So, with all that still selected, we'll
just go to home on the ribbon.
And then format and then auto fit column
width.
And that allows us to see all this data a
little bit more easily.
And now we'll edit the graph before I
finish up by summarising what we're
actually looking at here.
So, just make the graph bigger by clicking
and dragging the bottom right of the
graph.
OK.
So, there's a few things we need to do
here.
The first thing, we'll edit the name of
the graph.
So, instead of x variable one line fit
plot, we'll call this Heinz beta.
We don't need these labels here on the
right hand side, so we just select them
and press delete.
We want to be able to see our graph a
little better.
So, all these dots here, what you can do
is edit the size of these dots so they
aren't quite as intrusive and they don't
cluster quite so much, or they don't
appear to cluster as much.
So, if we just select one of the blue
dots, and actually click off again, and if
we just double click one of the blue dots,
and go to marker options, and change the
marker type to built in.
Reduce this to size 4.
So we can see a little bit more about what
we're dealing with.
Right, so the last thing to do, we'll
rename the axis labels.
So we can see a little bit more about what
we're dealing with.
Right, so the last thing to do, we'll
rename the axis labels.
The axis labels.
So first, the axis labels.
Reduce the size so we can see them all a
little bit better.
Reduce it to 4.
And do the same for the red dots.
So click off, and then double click one of
the red dots.
Marker options.
Built in.
Reduce this to size 4.
Okay, so we can see a little bit more
about what we're dealing with.
Right, so the last thing to do, we'll
rename the axis labels.
So first, the x-axis is the S&P 500.
And the y-axis is Heinz.
Okay, and we'll move these by clicking and
dragging those labels.
So it makes a bit more sense.
Okay, so this axis, horizontal axis,
represents the S&P 500 returns in relation
to the y-axis,
which is the Heinz returns.
And all these dots show, for a given week,
what the returns in Heinz were compared to
the
S&P 500.
And what we can see is that the S&P 500
generally increases at a higher rate, a
lot higher rate,
than the Heinz returns.
So let me just demonstrate that.
If you were to just eyeball this and look
across from 5% return on Heinz, and go
across.
Okay, 5% on S&P would be roughly here.
And none of our actual values are there.
Okay, so what that's saying is that the
S&P returns, for Heinz to have a return of
5%, the S&P
returns would generally be a lot higher.
So, tipping that on its head, what we can
say is, compared to the S&P 500, Heinz
returns a lot less, given a movement in
the S&P 500.
So, the sensitivity of Heinz to the
market, to the S&P 500, is low.
And that's what we'd expect, because this
is a consumer discretionary, sorry, a
consumer staple stock.
Meaning that it's less affected by the
business cycle.
There's always some demand, and so it has
fairly consistent returns.
It's a defensive stock.
Okay, so that's the graph explained a bit.
So, I explained what the blue dots are.
They're all the individual returns of
Heinz versus the S&P 500.
The red dots are, basically represent a
line of best fit between all the blue
dots.
Okay, so that's like our model line.
And the slope of that line represents the
sensitivity of Heinz to the S&P 500.
And so the slope of that line is also our
beta value.
And we're given the slope of that line in
this data summary output.
X variable 1 coefficient, so that's cell
J19, that's our beta value.
So our beta value is 0.38, roughly, of
Heinz.
Which makes sense, again, it's a defensive
stock.
So, I'm going to hand back to Anton now,
who's going to talk a bit more about what
we've discussed here.
And give a short summary on how you can
use beta, why it's useful and why we've
done what we've done here today.
Okay, welcome back.
So, what you just saw there from Chris was
really a step-by-step guide to calculating
your own beta.
You can actually go into the downloads
section and we've got a PDF there, which
takes you through the entire step-by-step
process to calculate your own beta.
As I said earlier, you don't really need
to go and do this for everything you do.
If you do actually manage to get, you
know, accurate beta online and you've got
a good resource for getting a beta that
has a decent time length, you shouldn't
worry about this too much.
You definitely do not have to do this
step-by-step for every single position
you've got in your portfolio.
That's just crazy.
I think, from a retail trader perspective,
the most important thing is that you've
got the right positions and then you
attempt as best as possible to hedge out
market risk if you want to go and do that.
Remember, you can actually be cash for
cash, as in long $10,000, short $10,000.
But if the betas are wildly different and
the beta ratio is high, that cash for cash
is not going to work very well as a trade.
So, you may want to try and hedge out as
much market risk as possible.
So, the step-by-step guide is there.
You can always refer back to the video if
you have some difficulties and watch Chris
go through that process again.
But, you know, definitely don't do this
for every single trade that you do.
That would just be doing too much work for
no real value add to your portfolio if you
can get the beta somewhere else.
The other thing that we've mentioned, you
know, in terms of this process, if you are
of the objective that you're going to work
in the industry one day, you want to work
at an investment bank, you want to work at
a hedge fund, then this is actually quite
important.
You do actually have to understand this.
If you are working at an investment bank
and a hedge fund for that matter, you
would be looking at your own portfolio and
you would be looking at what we call a
value at risk.
So, the amount of money that your
portfolio can make or lose per day on a
one standard deviation, two standard
deviation and three standard deviation
day.
And there's a lot of assumptions made by
the back office and middle office in terms
of the betas that they input into your
portfolio.
So, you'd actually have to understand this
process so you know when you're looking at
your portfolio what the real situation is
in terms of the value of money at risk
that you can make or lose per day.
So, if your objective is this, you should,
to work in the industry, you should
absolutely learn this inside out.
From a retail trader perspective, don't
worry about it too much.
You can go cash for cash.
If the beta ratio is high, you will
attempt to hedge out market risk as best
as you possibly can.
If you can get the beta publicly from a
decent website, then that's fine.
If you can't find beta anywhere, then try
and go through this exercise.
Okay.
So, now we're pretty much done with risk
management processes.
But, the last thing we have to do as a
trader in terms of having discipline is
having self-awareness.
Self-awareness of our own abilities as
traders.
So, that's what we're going to do next.
We're going to go over to video number 25
and start looking at some standard
industry metrics that measure your
performance as a trader.
So, you understand where your weaknesses
are and where your strengths are and what
you need to work on over the medium to
long term as a trader in terms of your
weaknesses.
So, let's go over to video 25 where we'll
be looking at the Kelly criteria.
Thank you.